the video of the moment New York City
police officer Daniel Pantaleo choked
unarmed black man Eric garner while
trying to arrest him five years ago
police say garner a 43 year old father
resisted arrest as he was being choked
he's heard saying his last words I can't
breathe his death led to the black lives
matter movement and months of protests
throughout the country against police
brutality against Blacks federal and
local authorities never brought criminal
charges against the police officer but
an internal investigation found the
chokehold did not conform with
department arrest procedures on Monday
Police Commissioner James O'Neal said
the officer would be fired in this case
the unintended consequence of mr.
Garner's death must have a consequence
of its own
therefore I agree with the Deputy
Commissioner of trials legal findings
and recommendations this is clear that
Daniel Pantaleo can no longer
effectively serve as a New York City
police officer Eric Garner's daughter
was happy the officer was fired but said
it's injustice her father was killed in
the first place I will do everything in
my power to never see another Eric
garner I don't even want to see another
video of a person being choked out
because it wasn't supposed to happen to
him and it's not supposed to happen I
should not be here standing with my
brother fatherless I should be here with
my father but Pantaleo took that away
from me on 717 the police union blasted
the decision saying the officer was just
doing his job trying to arrest an
uncooperative suspect anyone that has
been a police officer knows every second
counts
when you're getting possibly thrown
through a plate-glass window your
responsibility is to yourself the person
you're trying to arrest and everyone
else while there is disagreement if the
police officer should have been fired
all sides seem to agree on one thing
that five years was way too long
to reach a conclusion in this case now
the police commissioner is saying that
in the future the department will decide
much sooner on disciplinary action
against any police officer accused of
wrongdoing
Gabriel's Ando al Jazeera New York